Merci Stuart mon plaisir très agréable de
vous rencontrer et comme je le disais plus tôt
il plaisantait sur ce titre
propagande et démocratie et et le
fait que ces deux mots bien qu'ils
semblent antagonistes et contrariants ne sont pas
si éloignés et et tout votre travail et
tout ce qui  nous avons vu dans l'
émission documentaire que nous sommes dans un monde différent
aujourd'hui ou nous pensons que nous sommes dans un monde différent à
partir de quelle heure est-ce vraiment un
monde différent je veux dire qui serait quelle
serait sa réaction s'il revenait
aujourd'hui  il est mort quand il avait plus de cent
ans
102 et 102 donc il n'avait aucune réelle
implication dans l'ère numérique mais quelle
serait quelle serait sa réaction s'il
voyait le monde d'aujourd'hui avec des algorithmes avec du
big data avec toute la technologie qui
a envahi chaque  domaine de la vie eh bien, je
pense que nous sommes remplis d'idées que
tout est nouveau, c'est en partie le
produit de vouloir sentir que nous faisons une
certaine forme de mouvement dans la vie,
cela fait aussi partie de la façon dont les
médias pa  rtparticulièrement le travail des médias d'information
qui est particulièrement avec moi ayant un
cycle de nouvelles de 24 heures sur 24 fait partie de ce que font les
médias, c'est qu'ils comptent sur chaque jour pour
être nouveau, c'est pourquoi ils l'appellent des nouvelles
et et le résultat de cela est qu'il a
tendance à à  en même temps qu'il
favorise une fascination pour les
nouveautés du présent, il
efface tout et esis chaque jour consomme
les nouvelles de la veille et il génère
une sorte d'amnésie historique qui, je
pense, peut nous
empêcher de voir Edward Bernays rouler
à cheval et parmi nous
Bernays, je pense que je serais très heureux
que ce soient les technologies par exemple qui
sont utilisées avec les mégadonnées afin de
diagnostiquer les sentiments intérieurs des gens à travers
leur comportement en ligne, il se sentirait bien
c'est ce que je cherchais en retour  dans
les années 1920
je m'intéressais à comprendre
d'abord quelles sont les motivations qui
animent le public ou les masses je
m'intéressais aussi à comprendre
qu'il y a une sociologie française  Un ogiste du
début du siècle nommé Gabriel tarde
qui a écrit sur l'opinion et la conversation
et l'une des choses qu'il a dites c'était en
1898, il a dit que les gens s'assoient autour d'une table
et qu'ils ont une conversation mais
et ils croient qu'ils ne sont que le
deux ou trois d'entre eux ont une
conversation mais en fait la note le
rôle du journalisme et le rôle des
médias ont atteint un tel point que
leurs conversations ne sont plus les leurs,
ce sont leurs esprits et leurs
paroles suivent ce qu'il a appelé le  sillons
de leurs pensées empruntées et je
pense que très tôt
Bernays était quelqu'un qui cherchait
les voies ferrées pour ainsi dire ou les
réseaux le long desquels la perception
suivait la société l'utilisation des
mégadonnées qui est devenue un mot clé du
présent un  La phrase clé du présent est
simplement un raffinement
de quelque chose que Bernays
recherchait en termes plus primitifs, disons quand il a
commencé son travail au cours de la
Première Guerre mondiale
, alors vous avez cru  que les
fondements de sa pensée sa théorie
sont toujours là et que tout ce que nous avons
changé, ce sont les outils, l'échelle, la
capacité d'atteindre l'esprit et les comportements des gens,
mais sans savoir que cela n'a pas
fondamentalement changé la façon dont les choses sont
donc si vous  Je regarde quelles sont les
motivations et quelles sont les
stratégies ils n'ont pas changé sauf que
les outils ont changé mais je pense que
ce qui est intéressant je veux dire Jimmy nous
avons déjà parlé de la façon dont le livre de
propagande de René vient d'être publié en France
au cours des dix dernières années je devrais  ajoutez
qu'il vient d'être republié
aux États-Unis au cours des dix dernières années.
Bernays était un nom même s'il y a une
histoire que j'ai apprise quand j'étais étudiant selon
laquelle Beethoven et le philosophe
Hegel se tenaient au bord de cette
route et que Napoléon passait à côté  à cheval et
Hegel a entendu le Beethoven et il a dit que
nous assistons à l'esprit du monde à
cheval et Beethoven n'a plus jamais parlé à
Hegel Je pense que Bernays dans l'homme  y
manières représentaient l'esprit du monde
des tireurs de fil invisibles étaient
intéressés en quelque sorte par la gestion pas
tellement du consentement public mais je disais
juste au moment où nous étions assis autour d'une table
avant la question la fabrication du
consentement n'est certainement pas trop
douce  de le mettre parce que je pense
qu'il
s'agit du fabricant de l'obéissance et je
pense que c'est donc quelque chose
qui fait partie intégrante de notre monde et
certainement aux États-Unis,
il n'y a aucun moyen de comprendre le trumpisme
sans le comprendre comme le produit
de  le fabricant d'obéissance nous arrivons
à deux Trump évidemment il est une grande partie
de notre discussion mais pour continuer sur
cet aspect quand Internet et
les entreprises technologiques ont commencé elles étaient
considérées comme des outils de liberté de libération
de changer ce paradigme que
vous décriviez  et et et surtout
quand on pense à la devise de Google ne sais
pas le mal comment se fait-il qu'on n'ait pas vu
qu'au début c'est compliqué
question parce que l'internet a été
développé par l'armée américaine il n'a pas été
développé simplement par un groupe de chercheurs de liberté
et il y a un livre qui est
récemment sorti aux États-Unis
le titre des sorcières a échappé à mon ancien esprit
[Musique]
qui traite de ce genre  d'étranges
relations entre le militarisme et
les utilisations d'Internet, mais je oui, je
veux dire, je pense que ce que beaucoup de gens ont
vu, c'est qu'Internet a créé
une fois de plus la place publique où tout le monde pouvait
participer aux discussions, c'était
fondamental pour les idées de démocratie car
elles  a évolué au 18e siècle
ici aux États-Unis et ailleurs,
mais je dirais beaucoup la France aux États-
Unis, donc
la différence est bien sûr qu'Internet
est une place publique d'
individus isolés et donc la relation
entre cette place publique et le
la possibilité de sensibilisation du public en tant que
débat public et public et l'
activisme public est compliqué parce que vous avez des
gens assis devant  de leurs écrans
apprenant qu'il a été témoin de l'histoire d'une manière très
isolée, de sorte qu'en même
temps, il offre la possibilité d'un
type d'interaction qui était auparavant
sans imagination, il serait public, ce qui, je pense,
représente un énorme problème en termes
de notre avenir, mais  qui serait l'
avantage d'aujourd'hui seriez-vous un
ingénieur en informatique qui conçoit des algorithmes
vous connaissez une des raisons pour lesquelles chaque
Bernays est intéressant et a été
traduit en français au cours des 10 dernières
années et a été traduit en
anglais a été publié à nouveau en
anglais  dans West ici 10 ans
aux États-Unis avec un autre de son
livre précédent qui s'appelait
cristalliser l'opinion publique qui est
sorti en 1923 l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
Bernays est republié est parce
qu'il parle à la génération actuelle c'est
-à-dire que je connais un  beaucoup de jeunes
qui ont été impliqués dans des formes contemporaines
de persuasion et d'influence qui reviennent
à Bernays comme à bien des égards le vous
voulez  parler du pape
[Musique] que
vous connaissez comme le primat du saint
primat de la persuasion, il avait l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles le film de Jimmy résonne aujourd'hui,
c'est parce qu'à bien des égards, Bernays est comme je l'ai
dit avant, il est l'esprit du monde de
notre temps, il était  non seulement il y avait
beaucoup de gens comme Bernays, l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles nous connaissons Bernays est parce
qu'il a écrit sur lui-même, il était différent de la
plupart des gens des relations publiques qui aiment rester dans
les coulisses.
Bernays était un auto-promoteur, il a écrit un
livre au-delà de ces livres, il  a écrit dans les
années 1920, il a écrit une autobiographie qui
s'appelait la biographie d'une idée
prenant essentiellement toute cette idée de
propagande et la faisant sienne, mais
Bernays faisait partie d'une génération de
personnes qui avaient travaillé dans la
machine de propagande militaire qui s'appelait le
Comité  sur l'information publique pendant
la Première Guerre mondiale et ce qui s'est passé
pendant cette période, ce sont des gens qui étaient
des gens des médias des experts en persuasion des
publicistes des journalistes des cinéastes des
orateurs publics et ainsi de suite  avant tout Dieu a recruté
dans le Comité de l'information publique
qui s'appelle dans le film la
Commission creel après que l'homme qui en était
le chef, la Commission creel a été
démantelé sept jours après l'
armistice, mais vous aviez tout un tas de
gens qui étaient sortis  du
journalisme localisé, du cinéma, de la radio, etc. qui ont maintenant
compris comment appliquer leur métier à une
grande échelle nationale et internationale
et vous avez donc eu l'émergence dans les
années 1920 de
ce qu'un spécialiste du domaine a appelé
les professions de la conformité.
Bernays était un représentant de son temps.
n'était pas simplement un individu isolé, il
était la raison pour laquelle je pense qu'il est devenu
si important, c'est parce que la plupart d'entre eux
savaient mieux que de parler de ce qu'ils
faisaient, mais Bernays parle
beaucoup du présent et comme je l'ai dit, les
jeunes que je connais  qui travaillaient dans
qui dans le marketing de guérilla la gestion des
données du marché des données de réalité virtuelle
et ainsi de suite ce sont des gens qui
se tournent vers Bernays c'est e  c'est le
lectorat c'est pourquoi il est à
nouveau publié vous avez mentionné Donald
Trump et sa victoire a ouvert les portes
à de nombreuses questions de nombreux débats qui sont
au cœur de nos discussions mondiales
aujourd'hui sur les fausses nouvelles évidemment sur les
manipulations sur les post-vérités vous savez que
ces concepts sont sortis de  Je veux dire qu'ils
existaient mais ils sont devenus un
problème de débat public après que Trump a remporté les
faits alternatifs qui étaient un autre de ces
concepts que se passe-t-il qu'est-ce que
Trump a commencé nous vous savez quand nous avons
affaire à Edward Bernays à propos des
manipulations sur la formation de l'
opinion publique  que nous dit Donald Trump à
ce sujet, je pense que l'une des
choses centrales à propos de Trump est
qu'il a bouleversé le monde,
c'est-à-dire que la vérité est toujours arrivée
aux idées le
journalisme n'est pas simplement une
collecte scientifique de données qui est ensuite
présenté au grand public sous une
forme tout à fait objective, le journalisme a
toujours eu des motivations et des visions derrière
lui.  et il y a cent ans, le
philosophe américain William James a écrit un livre
intitulé pragmatisme et dont j'ai
parlé dans les relations publiques et je dis que j'en ai parlé dans les
relations publiques. J'ai écrit ce livre il y a 22 ans et
regardez, je suis ici l'
une des choses qu'il a écrites  dans son
livre sur le pragmatisme, il dit que c'était un
chapitre intitulé pragmatisme concept de
vérité et il y dit que la vérité n'est
pas qu'elle n'est pas le résultat de
quelque chose qui lui est inhérent la
vérité arrive à une idée elle est faite
vérité  à travers un processus de présentation
et de vérification et c'était une
idée importante parce que d'une part c'était une
idée très démocratique cette idée que nous
ne devrions pas accepter les vérités qui nous ont
été transmises par les papes et les rois
mais d'autre part  a ouvert l'
idée que si la vérité peut arriver à une idée
que si vous la dites suffisamment, elle deviendra
la vérité maintenant pendant longtemps dans
les institutions américaines comme l'
idée dans comme la télévision New York Times CBS
divers autres Wash  ington
posts et ainsi de suite c'étaient des institutions
qui transportaient l'eau impure de la vérité
J'ai regardé l'édition internationale du New York Times
c'est très
différent de celui que nous obtenons à la maison
c'est plus critique à certains égards
que celui que nous obtenons à la maison  mais aussi l'une
des choses qui y manquent, c'est
qu'en haut de l'ours du
New
York Times aux États-Unis, sur le
côté gauche, sur le côté droit, il y a la météo
et sur le côté gauche, il y a une boîte qui dit
tout le  des nouvelles qui peuvent être imprimées d'
accord, donc ce que cela signifie, c'est que pendant
longtemps, il y a eu ces certaines autorités
qui ont été considérées d'une certaine manière
comme les présentateurs non pas de la vérité donnée par Dieu
mais de la vérité donnée par la recherche et
et ils nous ont il y avait  un certain
type d'arrogance qui accompagnait le fait
que c'était très différent d'un endroit
comme Fran nous n'avons jamais eu le Brasel d'accord
nous n'avons jamais eu un journalisme vraiment
diversifié en termes de c'est comme si
nous n'avions pas de fêtes vraiment
divers, nous avons les deux faces d'une même
médaille en termes de système politique, donc
ce que Trump a fait, comme je l'ai dit, il a
renversé le monde, il a transformé
les arbitres traditionnels de la vérité en
pourvoyeurs de mensonges, ce qui dans une certaine
mesure était vrai, je veux dire le  Le New York
Times a vendu la guerre en Irak au peuple américain
en présentant un journalisme
emballé par l'armée américaine et ce n'est
que deux ou trois ans après le
début qu'ils ont fait une intense
autocritique pour ce oui où ils ont
commencé à se critiquer  car pour avoir
véhiculé l'idée d'armes de
destruction massive et cette fois l'autre
chose c'était un spectacle de marionnettes, donc ce que
Trump a compris, c'est que si vous avez un
système où il y a toujours des marionnettistes
impliqués dans la présentation des nouvelles et
nous sommes particulièrement  certains
juifs du public américain se sentaient très
limités ou amputés de la
vision de la vérité qui était présentée
dans ces médias, il était très facile
pour beaucoup de gens de  voir les médias grand public les
médias commerciaux qui
travaillaient tous pour l'entreprise le
système commercial qui s'était effondré au niveau
international dans une certaine mesure en 2008
pour voir cela comme une machine de propagande
et il a donc pris le terme propagande ou
fausses nouvelles qui est je suppose une autre
terminologie  et et montré comme un
projecteur sur les médias grand public,
cela signifie-t-il que dans ce récit, Trump
serait comme une résistance, un
mouvement de résistance à un Bernays de droite et
la fabrication de préoccupations, je ne
pense pas, alors je pense à ce qu'il ferait  est
mieux comprendre Bernays que le New
York Times ne les aurait pris à
leur propre jeu, eh bien vous savez que vous
parliez au début de la
terminologie de la propagande et de la démocratie
et il y a beaucoup de ces
contradictions apparentes qui vivent dans notre
monde, je veux dire  il y a un écrivain
aux États-Unis qui est venu et a
vécu à Paris pendant un certain temps
Tallahassee Coates qui a écrit un merveilleux
article de journalisme  appelé le cas des
réparations qui est une histoire sur les
politiques qui sous-tendent les systèmes de
racisme aux États-Unis et en
particulier concernant les Noirs
et l'une des choses dont il parle
là-bas est la mesure dans laquelle la démocratie
et la suprématie blanche ont été étirées étaient des
compagnons de lit et moi  c'est je pense probablement
vrai en France ainsi qu'aux États-
Unis nous ne sommes pas très différents et bien nous
savons que si vous savez je veux dire et le
colonialisme et l'impérialisme sont simplement
des moments différents dans une longue tendance donc la
propagande s'est développée à cause de la
démocratie
Bernays  était intéressé puisque les gens
avaient l'idée arrogante que leurs
idées comptaient et que leurs propres
pensées comptaient
Bernays s'est rendu compte que les anciens systèmes de
gouvernement ne fonctionnaient plus l'
aristocratie,
plus ils étaient hautement ecclésiastiques, plus ils n'étaient plus pertinents et
donc ce qui était nécessaire était la création
d'ingénieurs invisibles
qui utiliseraient des outils scientifiques et il en
parlait ainsi comme un moyen de
m  gérer la démocratie afin que les gens puissent
croire que leurs propres voix étaient
entendues et qu'en même temps le
pouvoir exécutif serait en mesure de faire ce qu'il voulait
à ce sujet ce que Trump a fait, c'est qu'il
a attaché sa politique à certains
sentiments largement répandus dans
Aux États-Unis, pour revenir à ce que
j'ai dit à propos de Coates, l'idée de la
suprématie blanche est quelque chose qui offrait même
aux Blancs les plus pauvres un sentiment de
supériorité, un sentiment d'importance d'une
manière que les autres personnes sombres n'avaient pas d'
importance, cela leur offrait un  le sens de l'
importance et une partie de ce qui s'est passé
dans la période qui a suivi, je dirais, la
Seconde Guerre mondiale, mais de manière très dramatique
dans les années 50, 60 et 70, c'est que
ces
points de vue vraiment submergés ont
tout d'un coup commencé à prendre une voix
.  publié par des personnes qui
étaient auparavant considérées comme analphabètes
et Trump a compris le ressentiment de
cela et il est lui-même un produit de ce
ressentiment le père de Trump qui était où
il a obtenu l'argent d'un agent
immobilier qui a interdit aux Noirs de vivre
dans tous ses projets de logement, mais qui a
également défilé avec le Ku Klux Klan dans
les années 1920, en d'autres termes, Trump venait d'
une famille qui se consacrait à la
suprématie blanche.  la capacité d'appeler les
Mexicains des violeurs et des criminels n'est pas
différente de ce que le Klan a dit à propos des
Noirs émancipés à la fin du
19e siècle,
donc Trump et ce qu'il fait et c'est
quelque chose que je suppose que vous avez vu quand
Trump ne ressemble à aucun politicien que j'ai
vu  quand Trump parle et qu'il organise des
rassemblements tout le temps, je n'ai jamais vu un
président organiser des rassemblements tous les deux
jours et dans ces rassemblements, il se rend dans des
endroits qui sont amicaux avec je dirais
ses idées sur le fait de donner le pouvoir aux
impuissants,
vous savez défendre le blanc  la suprématie
contre l'empiétement d'autres
nistha transformait l'Amérique en un
endroit méconnaissable et il prononce
ces discours mais chaque fois qu'il prononce un
discours, il recrute également des personnes pour stan  d
derrière lui donc chaque fois que vous le voyez dans un
rallye, ce n'est pas seulement Trump sur le podium
mais vous voyez des centaines de personnes derrière
lui qui ont toutes été entraînées par une
personne avancée pour applaudir follement
tout ce qu'il dit et qui l'ont également
été je dirais
tatoué avec de petites représentations de la
diversité, vous verrez donc un visage noir
et ce visage noir est au-dessus d'un corps
qui porte un t-shirt blanc qui dit
Noirs pour Trump, vous verrez quelques
femmes malgré le genre de misogynie qui
court  à travers son mouvement qui sont des femmes
pour Trump, mais pour la plupart, c'est un
groupe de camionneurs portant des chapeaux rouges qui disent
que l'Amérique est à nouveau grande,
ce qui signifie en passant que beaucoup de
gens rendent l'Amérique blanche à nouveau, faisons de l'
Amérique quelque chose qui a
supprimé  l'histoire, donc à bien des égards,
c'est l'utilisation de ce symbolisme d'
être un homme du peuple et d'
avoir réellement les gens derrière vous sur scène, je
veux dire que c'est remarquable et que ce soit
fait par génie intuitif ou
moi  Je pense que ce n'est pas un
intellectuel, en fait, il fait appel très
profondément à l'anti-intellectualisme qui
fait partie de la force vitale de la
société américaine, alors Woody fait une béarnaise
sans avoir de notes à órdenes, il
connaît probablement quelqu'un qui lit un  les vrais
Bernays, vous savez qu'ils sont là, mais pour
la plupart, son style est que vous savez dans
la culture populaire américaine, vous le savez tous à
cause des films de
la culture populaire américaine, il y a deux genres
qui ont été dominants, l'un d'eux est
l'occidental et le  chose de John
Wayne ou d'autres et de l'Occident, la chose à
propos de l'Occident est qu'il met en évidence l'
individu qui ne répond à personne d'
autre qu'à lui-même et vous savez certainement que c'est
en quelque sorte une représentation d'un
comportement libertaire à ne pas faire
et il tuera n'importe qui dans  son chemin et
cela fait partie du charme laid de la
tradition occidentale l'autre tradition est les
films de gangsters et Trump sort d'un
film de gangsters Trump est que vous devez
réaliser qu'il est sorti de la construction
Quiconque a passé suffisamment de
temps à New York pour observer le fonctionnement de l'
industrie du bâtiment sait que l'
industrie du bâtiment, historiquement, ainsi
que quelques autres industries comme l'
assainissement, etc.,
ont été dirigées par la mafia ou
par d'autres organisations mafieuses.  et donc si
vous allez faire des affaires à New York,
vous devez savoir à qui payer et vous
devez savoir à qui faire confiance et à qui ne pas faire
confiance et il y a une sorte de lien sacré
qui commence à se développer entre ceux-ci et
le  les gens que vous payez et ce
lien sacré repose sur l'idée
que vous les paierez, mais s'ils
se retournent contre vous, vous les aurez, vous les
ferez anéantir alors que les gens autour de
Trump ont commencé l'enquête
ça continue de se retourner contre lui il
utilise le langage de la foule pour décrire les
gens qui se retournaient contre lui tu sais
ce gars est un gars loyal c'est un bon gars
c'est un bon gars celui-ci est un flipper
je ne sais pas comment ça se traduit en
français b  ut c'est le jargon du
gangstérisme et et quiconque travaille dans
certaines entreprises à New York et
c'est vrai depuis longtemps J'ai grandi avec
ces enfants d'accord beaucoup de mes amis
leurs pères étaient des gangsters J'ai grandi
dans le Queens pendant une longue période  de temps
c'est de là que vient Trump c'est un
monde imprégné de gangstérisme je le
comprends instantanément parce que je travaille
dans une université qui fait partie du
système politique de cette ville de New York et j'ai
vu des gains se produire au sein de l'
université où Dean remettait de l'
argent  aux professeurs docilement vous savez
et pour rien juste vous savez que vous et mon
ami nous prenons un verre ensemble après le
travail d'accord voici 100 mille dollars passez
un bon moment donc cela fait partie de la culture
et Trump fait appel à cela parce que dans les
histoires de gangsters tout comme dans le
Les histoires occidentales, les meurtriers sont toujours
les héros, vous savez, les tueurs sont
toujours un peu romantiques et le fait
qu'il mette une casquette de baseball rouge qui
est devenue, vous savez, un signe de  la
culture des camionneurs qui était également dans l'industrie, les
Teamsters, qui ont une longue histoire d'
association criminelle et aussi et
ce qui s'avère être le cas,
c'est qu'il s'est entouré pour
drainer le marais, il s'est entouré
vous savez avec le marais qu'ils ont l'un
des  les aspects les plus frappants de la scène américaine d'aujourd'hui de
la scène d'ici au
moins
est la polarisation est le fait que les
américains ne lisent pas les mêmes nouvelles ne
croient pas les mêmes sources vous êtes soit
Fox News ou New York Times et et et
ainsi de suite  la base de la société pour la communauté
n'existe plus, c'est que quelque chose
que Trump utilise,
je pense que c'est d'abord quelque chose qui
s'est produit à la minute où ils ont
remplacé les cheminées et les maisons par des
télévisions qui, soit dit en passant, vous êtes un
grand pessimiste en
moi  je ne suis pas pessimiste je suis optimiste
parce que je pense qu'il y a du changement c'est
difficile on en a parlé l'autre
soir on vit dans un monde certainement
aux États-Unis où les gens sont u  sed
à la gratification instantanée, ils veulent le
changement et ils le veulent maintenant en tant
qu'historien, l'une des choses que vous voyez est que
le changement prend du temps et je pense qu'à
côté de cette division de la société
et de l'utilisation des mégadonnées pour
systématiser cela a été largement  noté,
mais avec cela, il y a un
mécontentement généralisé à ce sujet et
donc l'une des choses qui s'est produite
alors que lorsque Trump se rend au Michigan ou
partout où il va et que la foule
applaudit le lien,
ils ont été entraînés à applaudir derrière lui
lorsque les journalistes viennent  à eux et leur dire
pourrait-il jamais dire quelque chose qui pourrait
vous contrarier les gens disent en fait non je
crois tout ce qu'il dit donc ce n'est
pas un groupe de personnes qui sont même
orientés vers la démocratie ce sont des gens
qui sont amoureux c'est vous savez qu'ils
ont projeté  sur lui les choses mêmes
qu'ils ont ressenties mais
gênés de dire qu'ils projettent sur lui
les choses qu'ils disent manquer de leur
propre vie mais en même temps la
population de t  es États-Unis
changent cet organe massif
s'organisent au niveau local les gens
se réunissent d'une manière que je trouve
très prometteuse le fait qu'un socialiste
ou quelques socialistes aient atteint des
postes de pouvoir aux États-Unis
c'est quelque chose qui a  ne s'est pas produit
en cent ans où il y en avait quelques-
uns, alors à qui faites-vous référence à
ceux qui ont remporté le et rákóczi bien sûr
les primaires dans le
crédit pour le moyen terme le
républicain est et c'est l'autre chose à
propos de Trump qui est si intéressante  il est
il est détesté dans sa propre ville
là où nous avons été nous avons reçu la
grosse dose de Trump remontant à l'époque
où il était vous savez un playboy sur la
couverture du magazine The Enquirer et et les
gens pensent très mal à  lui, à
certains égards, il correspond à une sorte de
mythologie américaine du citadin qui vient
dans les petites villes américaines et trompe
les gens, vous connaissez les gens ordinaires, mais cette
fois, les gens ordinaires aiment ça, mais
il y a  d'autres choses qui se passent,
je veux dire qu'il y avait une histoire récente histoire récente
mais une recherche récente sur la
population des États-Unis en 19
2018, le pourcentage de la
population née à l'étranger
est supérieur à ce qu'il a été
aux États-Unis depuis  1910 qui était
au milieu de la grande migration de
personnes du Mezzogiorno d'Italie et
d'Europe de l'Est et ainsi de suite
et ces personnes ont également été souillées
et Trump, d'une certaine manière, fait écho à la
vision des forces
anti-immigrées puissantes anti-immigrées  les forces de l'
époque, les énormes fourmis qui faisaient la
promotion de l'eugénisme comme moyen d'essayer de
saper la fertilité des êtres inférieurs
et tentent également des tentatives très réussies
visant en particulier les
Noirs pour les décourager ou les
empêcher violemment de voter et ce
truc est  donc à bien des égards, je pense que Trump
est un retour au genre de
démagogie dont Bernays s'est inspiré
ou dont Gustav Lebon s'est inspiré, il n'est
pas une technique  rat ce n'est pas quelqu'un d'accord
monsieur mais c'est dû à ce que
vous venez de dire dans les dernières pages de votre
livre PR vous êtes optimiste quant à
l'influence de l'éducation mais l'éducation aux médias
sur le fait que par rapport
au début du 20e  siècle,
il y a évidemment un accès beaucoup plus grand
à l'information à la connaissance - qui est
plus démocratique et ouvert et
puis au cours des 20 dernières années, nous avons ce
sentiment que nous reculons, l'
histoire ne fait pas qu'avancer, c'est
une partie du  Idée
de progrès des Lumières mais je dirais deux
choses et une en termes de retard si
vous allez terminer un livre sur les
pouvoirs de la persuasion, vous voulez également
encourir des tireurs de fil d'ambre qui se tiennent
derrière l'instrumentation de la persuasion
je pense  il est juste d'encourager votre
lecteur à croire qu'il y a une
possibilité de quelque chose de mieux parce que les
médias étudient s'il ne s'agit que de toutes
les façons dont les médias baisent avec
nos esprits dans lesquels elle est moi  Amérique, nous
dirions pardonner mon français, mais si c'est
tout ce que vous faites, alors, d'une certaine manière,
vous encouragez un sentiment d'
impuissance et l'une des choses à
propos d'un sentiment d'impuissance est que
cela rend les gens impuissants, donc c'est
essentiel pour  les gens à imaginer leur propre
pouvoir potentiel non pas en tant qu'individus mais les
gens comme une alphabétisation sans valeur mais majeure
est un sujet très intéressant parce que je
veux dire qu'il y a un on en parle beaucoup
en France que le gouvernement a
annoncé qu'il doublait le
budget pour  l'éducation aux médias dans les écoles, par
exemple, est considérée comme un moyen de contrer les
fausses théories du complot et de
créer de meilleurs citoyens pour l'avenir,
il n'y a aucune preuve réelle que cela fonctionne
ou quand vous regardez les États-Unis  eh bien, tout
d'abord, nous devons examiner la question
de l'alphabétisation et ce que cela
signifie, car certaines personnes dans le monde des
affaires au début du
20e 20e siècle ont dit qu'il
fallait apprendre aux travailleurs à lire pour qu'ils
pourrait suivre les ordres une meilleure alphabétisation a
une histoire, la plupart des gens n'ont
jamais été alphabétisés et la raison pour laquelle l'
alphabétisation est devenue un problème, en particulier dans
les mouvements sociaux du 19e siècle, du
18e siècle et même du 20e siècle, c'est
parce que l'alphabétisation n'est pas simplement quand
on nous donne l'alphabétisation  ou les enfants
du 19ème siècle ont été initiés à l'
alphabétisation, ce n'était pas pour qu'ils
puissent comprendre tous les mensonges qui leur
étaient racontés dans les livres qu'ils
lisaient en d'autres termes oui c'est quelque chose que
vous devez pouvoir regarder  car vous
devez être humble pour comprendre la
manière dont la rhétorique d'une part, si elle est
correctement utilisée, peut éclairer les gens si
elle est mal utilisée, elle peut masquer la réalité d'une
manière qui incitera les gens à agir
ag  dans leur propre intérêt, mais l'
alphabétisation l'idée d'alphabétisation et les
mouvements pour un affable quel est le terme
et c'est l'alphabétisation le
mouvement vers l'alphabétisation l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles et a été un
élément si fondamental des mouvements sociaux populaires
est d'élargir l'univers
de  discussion, l'idée n'était pas seulement d'
apprendre à lire mais d'apprendre à
écrire et avec l'idée
qu'apprendre à écrire élargirait en fait
l'éventail des idées qui sont venues à la lumière
les idées de personnes qui ont été
historiquement
réduites au silence par le  écrire ce que nous appelons le compte
rendu de l'histoire et donc je pense que
s'il est vrai que nous sommes dans une période sombre en
termes de développement ou d'utilisation
de la psychologie de masse pour mobiliser les gens de
manière très très dangereuse en
même temps, c'est un  période de temps
où il y a une explosion d'écrits
qui donnent la parole à des idées et
qui n'ont pas été entendus avant je veux dire j'ai
mentionné devant le Tallahassee Coates
son essai sur t  le cas des réparations
prend ce genre d'institution de
racisme le meurtre d'hommes noirs par la police
qui fait partie des nouvelles quotidiennes et
dit attendez une seconde ce n'est pas seulement
quelque chose qui se passe maintenant, c'est
quelque chose qui se passe parce qu'il
y a une histoire de politiques qui ont assuré
la ghettoïsation des Noirs et et d'une
certaine manière, il s'agit de rendre le
présent lisible en fournissant aux
gens une mémoire historique et je pense que
c'est en quelque sorte l'une des tâches de l'alphabétisation
et c'est quelque chose qui se passe
regardez regardez le film de Jimmy je veux dire ça fait
partie de  l'univers de la discussion mais
si je peux vous avez vous avez été très
critique envers les médias aux états-unis  et
et cela s'appliquerait probablement à la France ou à l'Europe
de la même manière si
vous viviez ici et et certaines de
ces critiques sont certainement légitimes
et et et elles sont partagées par de nombreuses personnes
mais en même temps, les
alternatives ne sont pas sorties
le  les médias sociaux que nous voyons à un
moment donné et je le sais parce que lorsque nous avons
lancé notre site Web et oui, je faisais
référence à trop de choses, nous avions cette
idée que les gens prendraient le contrôle des
médias sociaux et produiraient
des nouvelles pas nécessairement alternatives mais plus larges et une meilleure
façon de  utiliser cela ne s'est pas produit et
puis aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés aux
yeux crédibles [ __ ] bien médias moins crédibles
je ne suis pas sûr d'avoir inventé un nouveau
monde des médias moins crédibles et des médias sociaux
qui n'ont pas été vous savez qui
sont devenus des champs de bataille pour  des
idéologies rivales ou des groupes haineux et nous nous retrouvons donc
avec un nouveau système moins fiable et moins
crédible ouais eh bien je pense que
le nouveau système est de tous les côtés a
contribué à cela parce que le
fait même que chacun  jour où vous devez publier un
autre journal et qu'il doit
contenir des choses qui sont nouvelles, je veux dire et
Trump est excellent dans ce domaine
dont Gustav Lebon a parlé lorsqu'il a
parlé des dirigeants de la fin du 19e
siècle, je suis désolé de  revenir en arrière lorsque
vous avez posé des questions sur le présent parce que je
pense que la mémoire est importante et je pense que
la perte de mémoire et le type de
diminution de la mémoire sont l'une des choses les plus
dangereuses parmi nous lorsque Ray
Bradbury a écrit son livre fire Fahrenheit
451 l'un des  les choses qui avaient créé
ce monde dystopique étaient que personne ne
pouvait se souvenir de rien
et l'effacement de la mémoire l'était
quand Mabon regarda les dirigeants de
la Commune de Paris de la fin du 19e siècle,
ce qui l'a vraiment effrayé, il a
dit bien les dirigeants ils parlent comme si
dans les images et chacun est placé
devant le suivant comme un
spectacle de lanternes magiques et ils n'ont aucun lien
les uns avec les autres et mais ils semblent
prouver qu'ils n'ont aucun lien logique les
uns avec les autres  mais ils deviennent une sorte de
pseudo-récit c'est ce que
fait Twitter Twitter est le spectacle de la lanterne magique
et le fait que nous ayons un président
des États-Unis qui était sur Twitter dix
fois par jour est un moyen de créer
une distraction constante du monde à
grand mais permettez-moi de revenir à ce que
vous avez dit au début vous avez dit que
je suis un critique des médias Je ne suis PAS un
critique des médias les médias sont des outils
d'expression publique Je ne suis PAS un critique
de la presse écrite  les
presses à imprimer sont quelque chose qui peut être utilisé
de manière émancipatrice et elle peut être utilisée
de manière répressive et donc la vraie
question est et je pense que c'est le
problème de l'alphabétisation que si nous voulons
dire si nous voulons dire ce que nous disons à propos de l'
éducation aux médias médias  l'alphabétisation doit
d'abord encourager un public à être
capable de regarder non seulement ce qu'est l'
information ou la désinformation des médias, mais
aussi comment les structures mêmes peuvent les
empêcher d'atteindre ce dont ils ont besoin
pour remplir leur mission démocratique.  c
aspirations et une autre chose qui
doit être faite est que nous devons briser
la distinction entre auteur et
public en d'autres termes c'est un journalisme citoyen
est quelque chose qui a un ver a eu un
impact très positif certainement
aux États-Unis le meurtre de  d'Eric
recueilli par un policier à Staten
Island, c'est quelque chose qui fait
partie de l'histoire américaine, les
policiers ont tué des hommes noirs
tant qu'il y avait des hommes noirs libres
et même quand il n'y avait pas d'hommes noirs libres, les
surveillants les tuaient  donc
c'est en partie, mais maintenant vous avez des gens
qui publient ce genre de choses, je pense que les gens
doivent s'imaginer en tant que
journalistes citoyens et ils doivent également
comprendre les moyens de se rassembler en tant que
communauté, en d'autres termes, lorsque quelqu'un
dit que nous avons fait une interview deux jours  il y a
et vous dites à quelqu'un que diriez-vous
à quelqu'un qui a dit que je ne veux pas
être manipulé et je dirais tant
que vous vous considérez comme quelqu'un que vous étiez
s  sensible à la manipulation c'est seulement
quand c'est seulement quand vous vous comprenez
comme un Terrien comme faisant partie d'une
espèce qui a besoin de se découvrir
à nouveau c'est seulement quand cela se produit
que vous pouvez créer des médias qui sont en
fait critiques et interactifs non pas
interactifs en ligne mais interactifs dans
les rues, je veux dire, les rues sont très
importantes parce que lorsque les gens se
rassemblent dans les rues, le pouvoir tremble
lorsque les gens se réunissent en ligne, c'est
et la question, car encore une fois, est de savoir qui
contrôle la structure des médias et
qui contrôle les plates-formes
technologiques, la technique textuelle qu'ils font  Facebook Google
Twitter oui c'est un homme l'une des
choses qu'ils sont alliés ou ennemis dans ce
que vous venez de décrire bien je pense que c'est
intéressant parce que si vous regardez les
entreprises de la Silicon Valley et je
suppose que je ne sais pas
je ne suis pas au courant  avec l'équivalent
en France mais si vous regardez
nous qu'on utilise tweet là ok ok ok mais si vous
regardez oui parce que les chinois ont
développé  les alternatives ped sont
bien plus intelligentes, mais tant que les habitants de la
Silicon Valley sont ces contradictions intéressantes,
ils sont très socialement progressistes, ils
ont tendance à être socialement progressistes en termes
d'idées de droits de genre en termes d'
orientation sexuelle en termes de toutes sortes
de choses et ils soutiennent  à bien des égards, entre
guillemets, les causes libérales avec certains
à une exception près, le gars qui est à la
tête de PayPal est dans le 13 Peter
Thiel était au moins un partisan de Trump,
mais à part ça, ce sont des gens qui
étaient des fonctionnaires pour Obama mais le
fait est que  ils sont résolument
libertaires et il y a résolument
libertaire de manière à ce que, par exemple,
lorsque le gouvernement veut les
réglementer de quelque manière que ce soit, ils adoptent la même
position que l'industrie pétrolière adopte,
ils adoptent la même position que d'autres
monopoles mondiaux ont adoptée depuis
le début  jours de laissez-faire
et vous avez donc une situation dans laquelle vous
avez une sorte d'
ISM d'entreprise transnationale qui est le minimum économique  dset de la
Silicon Valley et
de ce que vous pourriez appeler un service de pure forme au
libertarianisme qui fonctionne à un
niveau plus public, mais j'étais ici pour dire
revenons à une discussion avant que le
problème ne soit que les gens qui sont les
propriétaires les capitaines de ces industries
ils  comprendre la motivation du profit et
ils sont motivés par le fait que beaucoup de
gens qui travaillent pour eux en termes de
savoir que les ingénieurs en informatique et ainsi de suite sont des
libertaires sans nécessairement
s'identifier aux motivations capitalistes
et donc vous avez une personne comme Edward
Snowden qui vient de  ce monde
qui qui qui a rompu avec les politiques de
la NSA mais aussi de la Silicon Valley mais
la Silicon Valley est la nouvelle colonne vertébrale
du capitalisme américain oui c'est
ça et c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
quand on parle de créer des
médias alternatifs il faut  trouver d'autres canaux dont nous avons
besoin pour créer d'autres canaux dont nous avons probablement besoin d'
aller plus loin dans la technologie, car la haute
technologie est invariablement liée à l'argent
et au pouvoir et parfois  imes vous savez je veux dire
dans les années 1960 une des choses qui
s'est passée au milieu de toutes les
activités qui se sont déroulées a été la création
en France du joueur italien
aux États-Unis la presse clandestine l'
armée même dans l'armée les
fantassins  les gens qui exécutaient
la guerre sur le terrain ont commencé à tirer sur des
officiers et ont commencé à produire
des journaux clandestins avec des
miméographes mais nous allons dans l'autre sens
je veux dire et oui je vous citais Valley il
il présente un avenir qui est vous savez l'
intelligence artificielle se mélangeant avec
cerveau humain et et une sorte d'
avenir technologique incroyable qui façonne notre monde
et crée différents types d'
inégalités et de luttes dans
ce monde, la question est de savoir où trouvons-nous
les alternatives qui font maintenant partie de l'
attrait de l'interaction cerveau-machine
est qu'il y a  sont certaines personnes qui
soutiennent que puisque nos cerveaux sont simplement des
ordinateurs, cela vient d'Alan Turing
la théorie computationnelle de l'esprit
où nous considérons l'ordinateur simplement
comme un fac-similé de la manière dont le
cerveau fonctionne réellement, il n'y a aucune preuve
de cela, en d'autres termes, si vous voulez
comprendre un immeuble en
regardant les réseaux électriques et les
réseaux de plomberie ne le fait vraiment pas
vous en dire beaucoup sur la vie de ce qui se passe
dans cet immeuble, mais une partie de
l'attrait de celui-ci ou de l'
attrait de l'interaction cerveau-ordinateur
est qu'il y a des gens qui
disaient qu'à l'avenir vous
pourrez avoir  votre cerveau est téléchargé sur un
lecteur quelconque et il
vous fournira l'immortalité, c'est-à-dire que
votre corps mourra mais votre
esprit continuera et sera ajouté à une
machine bien, je veux dire que c'est une sorte de
christianisme de haute technologie vous  sais que c'est
ceci est la promesse d'une vie après la vie
la promesse d'une vie après la mort
et je pense en fait que l'une des choses
qui doit être une réalisation urgente
parmi les gens est leur propre mortalité
parce que o  une fois que vous embrassez votre propre
mortalité, vous pouvez trouver un
sens à votre vie ce que vous faites
de votre vie c'est ce que votre ancien
patron jean-paul Sartre a dit la bonne vie en
elle-même ne prend de sens que
par l'engagement et je pense que c'est
vrai et je pense qu'en espérant que ces
avenirs déterminés par la technologie n'aient
rien de nouveau, c'est
quelque chose qui dure depuis toujours,
cela fait longtemps que je n'ai pas entendu
quelqu'un citer Joe Purcell une erreur, nous
répondrons à quelques questions du
public dans quelques instants  minutes, j'ai une
dernière chose que j'ai trouvée cette statistique que
j'ai trouvée stupéfiante en 2000, il y avait
65 900 journalistes aux
États-Unis et 128 000
personnes de relations publiques si merveilleuses - plus ou moins en
2015 15 ans plus tard, le nombre de
journalistes a baissé d'un  -troisième à quarante-
cinq mille huit cents et le
nombre de personnes chargées des relations publiques a augmenté - pour en vendre
200 mille et 18 000, donc c'est maintenant un
journaliste pour près de cinq personnes chargées des relations publiques.
ça dit à propos de notre monde c'est c'est je
veux dire en tant que journaliste je trouve ça
complètement effrayant et et et
hallucinant eh bien je pense que c'est effrayant mais
ça vous dit aussi que l'urgence de
fabriquer le consentement est devenue de
plus en plus grande et l'urgence de
travailler avec  un public informé est
devenu quelque chose qui
intéresse de moins en moins les structures du pouvoir,
donc en d'autres termes, vous pouvez regarder des
statistiques comme ça de différentes
manières, d'une part, vous savez que les gens ne sont
tout simplement pas intéressés à comprendre le
monde qu'ils  vivre et l'autre est
que peut-être que les gens sont intéressés à
comprendre leur monde et donc vous
devez mettre plus d'ingénieurs du consentement sur
le terrain afin de pouvoir
gérer ces désirs parce que je
ne pense pas que les gens  ont perdu leur
curiosité et je ne pense pas que les
gens aient perdu leur colère à propos des
inégalités de pouvoir, je et je devrais dire
bien que Trump, je veux dire, Trump est
cet homme de paille qui se met en quelque sorte  un
cirque invisible dans les médias au
quotidien, mais dans les coulisses, ce qui se
passe politiquement est horrible et
fait partie d'un
plan conservateur aux États-
Unis et je suppose ailleurs depuis
longtemps, mais ils n'ont jamais connu le
carnaval  aboyeur devant qui pourrait se
tenir devant la foule et la
distraire des problèmes de leur
vie parce que les inégalités économiques
augmentent la répression de la
souveraineté populaire et le vote augmente les
salaires des cols bleus stagnent
tandis que les revenus des très riches  pas
seulement 1% mais probablement les 10% que
vous connaissez garantissent que vous avez une
classe moyenne supérieure qui sera la
tête de pont de la politique conservatrice, mais en
attendant, vous avez des gens dans les Appalaches
qui ont été sans emploi et qui
luttent contre des problèmes de santé obésité  Je
veux dire toutes sortes de problèmes
et qui sont menés par le nez par
cet aboyeur de carnaval donc vous savez je veux dire
je pense qu'il y a très réel et je
pense que  au moment même où j'ai rencontré des
gens qui ont dit que j'aurais voté
pour Bernie Sanders,
mais j'ai plutôt voté pour Trump
parce que je n'avais aucune chance et je
pense que c'est un signe de la façon dont les
gens peuvent être manipulables et ils ne  Je ne peux pas faire
la différence entre l'un ou l'autre
mais c'est aussi qu'il y a cette sorte de
référentiel de bouleversement et de sentiment d'être
privé de ses droits de naissance qui peut
mener dans des directions différentes ce que nous
voyons en ce moment est que cela a conduit  à l'
élection de l'impossible président, mais
vous pourriez si vous regardiez ses rassemblements
dès 2015, il n'était pas difficile de voir
qu'il deviendrait président à cause des
trucs qu'il a fait ressortir chez les gens, vous
savez, cela dit aux gens de battre
quelqu'un qui le critique ouais allez dans
le passé nous les aurions emmenés
sur une civière dans le passé si je l'avais
frappé à la tête je voudrais
te frapper au visage c'est le
président qui parle je voudrais frapper
vous dans le visage et vous savez quoi  au coup
de poing au visage si vous obtenez une loi si un
procès arrive contre vous je vais
vous chercher mon avocat bien son avocat est maintenant
en charge donc c'est un problème merci
nous devons avoir des microphones s'ils
embrassent Joan oh mon  ça alors Rose ne projette pas,
ils connaissent aussi six primaires nous voient dire
dans le film que les gens qui ont
commencé avec cette propagande
qu'ils n'en verront pas la fin
iront de génération en
génération qui tu penses que  la
paire de cette chose où vous comprenez
ce que je veux dire dans le ridicule sur signal
Philip II une pop ou certaines émissions que
la génération de la propagande ne devrait pas dire
autoritaire CC un cercle camp Akili Appa
c'est une question importante en partie
parce que des tendances plus progressistes
au sein de notre  les sociétés ont tendance à ne pas penser à
travers les générations où nous avons ce
désir de gratification instantanée, mais je
dirais que si vous voulez parler d'un
individu en 1936, lorsque FDR se présente à la
présidence, il fait la guerre à la
classe des affaires qu'il appelle  eux les
royalistes économiques et que nous allons
leur retirer leur pouvoir, vous en voyez
un peu dans le film et donc à
partir de la fin des années 1930,
vous avez le rassemblement de diverses
organisations, l'une d'entre elles mentionnée dans
le film est la  National Association of
Manufacturers
qui continue d'être une puissance majeure
aux États-Unis vous avez la Chambre
de commerce qui continue d'être une
puissance majeure aux États-Unis vous
avez aussi un groupe de personnes qui sont
intéressées à créer une identification
entre le christianisme et Dieu  et le
capitalisme c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
sur l'argent américain il est dit In God We
Trust c'était quelque chose qui a commencé à
être promu dans les années 1930, il n'a
atteint les billets d'un dollar que dans les années 1950
et il a également eu le développement d'
organisations comme la Pelerin Society
ou le département d'économie de l'
Université de Chicago qui s'intéressait à
la vitalité du capitalisme
et à la longévité du capitalisme comme étant
en d  colère et ils ont établi des plans qui
étaient comme je l'appelle dans le film le long
jeu en d'autres termes, même si nous ne
vivons pas pour voir ce que nous créons, nous
devons le créer et avoir confiance dans le fait
qu'il atteindra ses objectifs  eh bien l'une
des personnes pour répondre
plus directement à votre question allemande qui a été recrutée
initialement par la National Association
of Manufacturers était un jeune
acteur hollywoodien du nom de Ronald Reagan et
Ronald Reagan dans les années 1940 est devenu un
porte-parole par exemple contre un système
national de santé  système qui était
sur le point d'être adopté il est ensuite allé travailler
pour General Electric on y va il avait un
tuteur de personne qui le
formerait sur ces voyages et il irait d'
usine en usine en argumentant contre le
syndicalisme et McCain et General Electric
ne feraient plus qu'un  des premières grandes
entreprises à développer des stratégies pour vous
en brisant Reagan puis est allé à la
télévision dans les années 1950 pour General
Electric, il avait un il était l'hôte d'un
programme appelé  Janet a appelé
le General Electric Theatre et la
devise du programme était General
Electric où le progrès est notre
produit le plus important dans les années 60 et 70,
il a été élu au poste de gouverneur de
Californie et en 1980, comme vous le savez tous, il
devient président des États-
Unis et  soit dit en passant, utilise l'
ingénierie du consentement d'une manière qui était
au moins une prémonition de Trump,
il n'avait pas le genre de bord dur
que Trump a, mais il avait une politique très similaire
et représentait une
politique similaire, c'est donc un exemple d'idées
qui  a commencé à percoler dans les années 1930
qui a finalement obtenu le pouvoir de l'État au
niveau présidentiel dans les années 1980 et
qui, je dirais, a continué
progressivement depuis lors, en particulier
lorsque vous avez, par exemple, le Parti
démocrate rompant avec le type même de
tradition des programmes de protection sociale
qui avait  été l'héritage du New Deal,
donc je considérerais certainement Ronald Reagan
et maintenant son genre de fantôme idolâtré comme un
exemple de pensée ab  sur le long jeu
où tracez-vous la ligne entre cette
idée qu'il existe une ingénierie qui est de
longue date et très efficace et les
théories du complot où si nous sommes
effectivement manipulés quelque part pourquoi ne
sommes-nous pas manipulés sur tout et peut-être
pas
allé au  lune peut-être qu'il n'y avait pas 911
peut-être que vous connaissez toutes les théories
qui circulent où
tracez-vous la ligne et comment
définissez-vous cette ligne J'ai tout un problème
avec l'expression
théorie du complot parce que quiconque a étudié l'
histoire le sait  il y a et il y a
eu des complots, je veux dire que la papauté a été
chassée de Rome et envoyée pour vous faire
savoir il y a des centaines d'années par un
complot l'assassinat d'Abraham
Lincoln alors qu'ils n'ont réussi
qu'à tuer Lincoln était un complot pour
anéantir la direction du
Gouvernement de l'Union par des personnes qui étaient d'anciens
confédérés, le terme théorie du complot,
je pense, est entré dans ce monde boueux
et, en passant, je ne pense pas que vous pourriez
stupéfait  l'histoire sans reconnaître que les
gens se réunissent dans des chambres certaines sur
Madison Avenue et nous le faisons maintenant ouais
complètement planifié en fait aucun de nous
n'est réellement ici si vous remarquerez que chacun
de nous a une petite clé derrière l'
oreille droite et nous avons été blessés  en quelque sorte sur le
chemin du théâtre, mon
printemps s'épuise en fait, mais non, je veux dire après le
changement après l'assassinat de Kennedy,
il y avait toutes sortes de
théories entre guillemets sur qui l'a fait
et bien sûr la position officielle du gouvernement
était en phase avec l'Amérique
l'individualisme c'était un tireur solitaire il n'y
avait pas de complot ne regardez pas l'homme
derrière le rideau
vous savez que c'était un tireur solitaire qui
s'est avéré commodément tué quelques jours
après avoir fonctionné comme un tireur solitaire afin
qu'il ne puisse jamais rien divulguer  ce qui
aurait pu le motiver et donc vous avez eu
toutes sortes de personnes orphelines
sans beaucoup d'informations spéculant sur
le fait que le meurtre d'un président
n'est probablement pas quelque chose  cela se produit
sans discussion préalable et donc
le terme théorie du complot est devenu un
euphémisme car vous connaissez bien les idées folles,
je pense que la façon dont nous pourrions faire la
différence est par enquête, en d'autres
termes, tout comme je veux dire l'une des choses
qui pour moi se distingue  le bon
journalisme du journalisme cinglé, c'est
que le bon journalisme est basé sur la
recherche où vous regardez autour de vous, vous creusez,
vous regardez sous les rochers, tout comme la bonne
histoire, vous passez à travers les ordures, vous
cherchez des trucs, c'est comme un
travail de détective et vous et je pense que les
gens  Je dois être capable de reconnaître cela,
mais je pense que le fait que le terme
théorie du complot n'ait été
lancé que de manière promiscuité comme une façon de
décrire même Trump, vous savez, Trump est
rempli de toutes ces
théories du complot, il a vu un groupe d'Arabes au-dessus
de  un bâtiment dans le New Jersey qui
applaudissait vous savez quand le World Trade
Center est tombé bien il ne l'a pas vu
il n'était pas dans le New Jersey mais et ce
truc qui peut  être découvert mais je pense
qu'effacer l'idée que des groupes de
personnes fonctionnent en accord les uns avec les
autres dans des complots Je ne pense pas que ce soit
une chose saine pour nous d'ignorer la
façon dont les intérêts interconnectés
fonctionnent dans l'histoire
non pas de soins médicaux si nécessaire  oui un
particulier Bernays vamos un terminar la
saint jean paul ii museo service Dokus
Capuano dans la pathologie un
homme nutrition aujourd'hui
Sepideh origine me renverra vers la
famille desiree car je merite post partum c'est
Eva Marcille mm Oh raison differente un
rapport perso jolie feminin bonjour nous
sont maintenant baiser baiser baiser tabous annum comme
service de métro voyez-vous dans le meilleur Diez de
pouvoir population Sasaki a donc proposé une
question grossière inverser la clé pour
dire attention à la population sainte double couche d'
homos - Leon Anita est si utile le
contrôle de la population de Dhokla dans p20 développer  c'était
vraiment la ville locale n'a pas d'hôtesse
vivant assis pose une
procédure douce Cosima crédible Roumanie Clarence est un
miracle pas d'herbe
d  oc Agatha ne Cecilia a Silicon
Valley
ne manquez pas un instant non dans l'espace la
cour toute la population générale sur
tauriel c'est une couche solide absolue Danny une
partie de l'évoquer un divot un peu de
capacités dramatiques c'est un biscuit - pas de fées se
reposent plus  excuses
estación sorte d'entreprise d'histoire sait
ne pas Yap a basura de PE pasa ou ne pas
visualiser à volonté voir
hmm vous avez posé beaucoup de bonnes questions
au milieu de votre question oui je
pense qu'il était intoxiqué par l'idée de
contrôler  les gens sa fille et
Béarnaise qui est dans le film dans une Varsovie que
je connais s'asseyaient à la table et disaient
que tout le monde était stupide tu es stupide
disait-il à ses filles et donc il
croyait que les quelques intelligents avaient une
responsabilité envers la démocratie afin  pour
faire en sorte que les masses stupides puissent
se comporter et il y avait beaucoup d'
argent en jeu qui est ce qui pousse les gens à
promouvoir la guerre contre son pays d'
origine d'abord il n'était pas un
béarnais n'était pas une figure majeure du
comité de Pu  blic
Information c'est son récit de l'histoire
Walter Lippmann et un gars du nom d'Arthur
Bullard étaient tous deux conseillers du président
et Wilson étaient les personnes qui sont venues vers
lui Wilson voulait utiliser la force pour faire
taire toute opposition et Lippmann et
Bullard ont fait valoir que nous devions  créer
un bureau de propagande et ils en sont devenus les
architectes et ils ont également choisi un
homme du nom de George Creel pour diriger la
Commission.
un
critique des affaires, ce qui était un
geste très intelligent dans une guerre souvent
critiquée comme une guerre d'hommes d'affaires.
mais
Wyler, il faisait partie du crépuscule des
idoles, vous connaissez les gens, les
intellectuels qui se sont conformés
à l'effort de guerre en termes de ce que vous
tu as dit à propos de l'immortalité, je comprends ce que tu dis et c'est qu'il y a
un enregistrement qui est maintenu,
c'était que les gens semblaient vraiment morts
ou vivants, puis ils ont été enregistrés d'
accord, donc quel est le genre d'
intermédiaire et je sais  ceci parce que je
mentionnais à Pierre avant que lorsque mon
père était mourant,
il était une personne très visuelle et il est devenu
aveugle et donc ma mère lui a acheté un
petit magnétophone et il parlait
dans le magnétophone tous les jours de
ses selles à propos de lui étant
nauséeux à propos de ses rêves de ne pas
vouloir se sentir morbide à propos de se souvenir de la
facilité pour lui et son père d'aller
aux bains du centre-ville dans le Lower East
Side et mon fils qui est éditeur a rassemblé cela
sur un CD afin que chacun de ces
petits souvenirs soit transformé en  comme une
coupure sur le CD et je l'avais sur mon ipod
et j'allais rendre visite à un ami et
j'écoute de la musique et tout d'un
coup j'entends mon père me parler à l'
oreille et c'était incroyable et je  je suis allé
voir cet homme qui était un de mes collègues
et je lui ai dit que tu sais que la chose la plus
étrange vient de m'arriver
j'écoutais de la musique et puis tout d'un
coup mon père a commencé à me parler
et j'ai pu entendre son souffle et  Je pouvais
entendre sa voix et c'était tellement différent
que de regarder une photo qui est
gelée et morte c'était en fait et donc je
comprends qu'il y a une sorte d'
immortalité
qui est possible à travers le et il
m'a dit encore et encore  moi, il a dit
tu sais mon mon père est mort quand j'avais 13 ans
et je donnerais toutes mes photos
si je pouvais avoir un enregistrement de lui
me parlant donc il ne fait aucun doute
qu'il y a ce terrain intermédiaire
mais je pense que ce qui est différent à propos
du  l'immortalité dont vous parlez,
qui est le type de données enregistrées,
c'est tout, mais il s'agit de transformer des
sujets en objets, en d'autres termes, l'
immortalité est l'immortalité d'un
objet, la subjectivité a disparu, je pense
que le mythe  ce qui est promu
sur le type de transfert du cerveau
sur un disque dur consiste à maintenir la
subjectivité que votre esprit, votre
conscience continuera et dans ce
cas, la conscience devient simplement une
donnée brute à exploiter à des fins d'autres personnes
, donc je ne dirais pas tout à fait  appelez cela l'
immortalité dans le sens où
certaines personnes le souhaitent merci pour
ce témoignage personnel était
très très très significatif pour notre sujet
aussi nous allons arrêter ça ici avant que
votre machine ne s'arrête merci beaucoup
Stuart et merci à tous  pour cette
grande conversation et permettez-moi de dire à tout le monde
que c'est l'un des grands plaisirs
de ma vie d'être ici avec vous, je suis
un homme d'environ 70 ans
et de savoir que vous connaissez des idées avec lesquelles
je lutte depuis  J'étais
très très jeune, mais la question est toujours d'
actualité, ce n'est pas une question d'immortalité,
c'est une question d'engagement, c'est le
but de la vie sur lequel votre vieil ami
Sartre a écrit de toute façon, merci beaucoup.
ch pour être facile
[Applaudissements]
vous